here's the biggest mistake companies
make when they're doing cultural
transformations they treat it like it's
a marketing campaign where here's the
launch date right
and here are all the programs we're
gonna make everybody go through and hear
all the powerpoints and hear all the
executives that are gonna give the
powerpoints you're nodding yes I'm
getting something right right and then
it doesn't work or people are resistant
or fight' or don't show up or even
sabotage and it's all well intended it's
imperfect and sometimes we get the
cultural thing wrong or the timing wrong
but it's all well intended and it falls
flat and it's a big waste of time in a
big waste of money and we're right back
where we started right there's something
called the law of diffusion of
innovations
this must be come your best friend okay
the bell curve all populations always
sift across the standard deviation if
you have high performers you have low
performance always and then you have an
average always in this room there's a
group of people I know who are nodding
their heads going yep yep yep yep
there's a group of people who think I'm
an idiot and I like I wasted my money
but most people are like I'm open yeah
this is interesting I like some of it
you know I know that I know that going
in every single time and the fact that
you all wanted to come and pay to me and
it's not a general industry thing then I
know that it's just a little more one
way or the other but it's still the
standard deviation always right what
does it what the law of diffusion tells
us is that the first two and a half
percent of our population are innovators
big idea people Steve Jobs you know
beyond musk then you have the next 12 to
13 percent of our population our early
adopters who are willing to sacrifice
time money and energy to be a part of
something that reflects their own
beliefs they stand in line to see the
new Star Wars for eight hours even
though you can just go in a week and
just buy a ticket and go in they thought
that was a good use of time and money
right then you have the next the early
majority the late majority and you're
the only reason these people do
something is because they have no choice
anymore right what you're asking for in
cultural transformation is this how do
we change our company right the problem
is the problem is is this this group of
people the majority they're cynical
they're practical
what's in it for me what do I get if it
goes wrong are you gonna pay me extra if
I have to stay late you know they're
cynical in their practical right these
people not so much right they'll just do
something cuz they think it's great and
they want to be a part of it what the
law of diffusion tells us is that you
cannot achieve mass-market success or
stickiness for a new idea until you
achieve 15 to 18 percent market
penetration it is the tipping point it
is a social phenomenon if you ignore
everything I tell you today about this
you will always get about 10 percent
that's what you'll say they just get it
we love them they get it and ten percent
of the company is gonna be all in it's
not enough and so this that Jeffrey
Moore called the chasm crossing the
chasm is the magical gap and the way you
get it you get it is you don't talk to
these people at all you ignore them and
you aim at these people only the early
adopters because these people do not
want to try something new until someone
else has tried it first and let me tell
you how it looks cuz I've done it so I a
large company many many more people than
is in your company 200,000 people wanted
me to help them do a Millenial training
program so I said great I pull out my
little pocket copy of the law of
diffusion because to me this is religion
by the way this is how I built my entire
career remember that story I told you
before it convinced me why I should hire
you he told me he was over here he
didn't tell me he was over here I could
hear that I ignored him for now I'll get
him later right someone else will get
him later so here's what we did what the
company wanted to do was traditional
they wanted me to design the program
we're gonna launch it we're gonna make
videos there were me to be on the videos
and then we're gonna have the training
program and we're gonna force all the
Millennials to go through the training
program it'll be amazing and I'm
thinking it's gonna fail so this is what
I said I said I'm gonna do one workshop
once and we will make it open to anybody
born after 1984 only which means if you
were born before 1984 you're not
eligible that keeps all the senior
executives out so they can't come and
watch and make sure and the people who
come in we only have a hundred and 100
seats 125 seats and they have to apply
because I want people to put in extra
time and extra energy and and the
problem with the internet is we've made
everything easy let's try and make
everything as so easy as possible click
like like a click you're in no I want to
make things a little bit difficult right
so they had to fill out a proper essay
and submit it and we actually read all
of them and we could tell who was
phoning it in and we could tell who
actually genuinely wanted to be there
and we selected a hundred a hundred
people and we only did it from the East
Coast offices just cuz it was
convenience we did New York he was on
the East Coast in New York and Virginia
right just cuz it was easier maybe a few
of the other offices actually there's
also Chicago and all that whatever a
bunch of the offices
I gave this wonderful workshop and at
the end of it I said hey guys we don't
have a Millenial training program we
want to do one so I'm asking for
volunteers from this room to help build
it you're not gonna get any extra money
you might have to work extra hours on
your own time and you may or may not
have this included in your compensation
of promotion packages at all
who wants in I had fifty volunteers who
said that they were gonna help build
this program for no additional money and
no particular personal benefit it's
because they believed in it right two
weeks later one of the senior executives
in the company calls me up furious at me
he's so angry at me do you know why
because leaders from across the entire
country were calling up screaming at him
why don't we get a Millenial training
program why is it only on the west coast
and I said congratulations that's called
demand because they all went back to
work and said this is amazing
right had I done a traditional way those
same leaders would have called up and
yelled why do I have to give up my
people for an hour and a half every week
I am busy we don't need this would have
been the exact same response so you want
to make it slightly difficult an
invitation voluntary and invite them to
actually help you build it because then
it has a grassroots nature and so now
you're doing things from the top and the
bottom so you have the formal corporate
stuff always voluntary and the stuff
from the bottom coming from them and you
help them and you give them resources
and then you create a scenario where you
can check in with them and they can all
check in with each other once a month on
a conference call and all share best
practices so that you can take something
that's working in one country and try it
in another country and you will learn
from them and you'll give them resources
and in time I don't know how long and
this is why companies don't like this it
100% works I just don't know how long 1
year 2 year 3 year I don't know depends
on the
company depends on the size depends on
the culture I don't know it a hundred
percent works so if you're comfortable
the fact that it'll work we just don't
know when this is your best friend your
early adopters and you say I'm very
honest about it I say we have this
program we're gonna have this cultural
transformation we're going from this to
this values base we're looking for a few
people who want to volunteer and four
people show up great they can an amazing
experience but make it a little bit
difficult I do this with senior
executives I did a workshop with the the
the top 40 I did it worked with the top
40 leaders of a major organization they
wanted to do a cultural transformation
so I hosted it as a non mandatory
meeting on Saturday 25 of them showed up
I knew that some of the good ones
couldn't come because their children
have a play or a game and some of the
bad ones
came because they have to make sure that
you know they're included on everything
but the majority were people who wanted
to be there because I asked them to come
on a Saturday and some of them had to
fly in from across the country and guess
what it was amazing so make it a little
bit difficult and this go read about
this it's you can just go sit in the
bookshop and read start with why it's
just it's one chapter in there you don't
have to buy the book just go read the
chapter but this is this is this is your
baby this is your baby
[Music]